[Music]
this is what candid sounds like JT holds
nothing back about his plans for
expanding the Timberlake family and
being a parent everybody tells you
though your life's gonna change you like
yeah whatever I got it my wife and I
like each other when we have a you know
a night off and we get him to bed and we
sit down and just like watch a movie or
something and we're like what do we do
before they're calling life pre stylist
a blur I've never felt more inept in my
life my three year olds already running
our house et seen over the years that
Justin and Jessica's approach to
parenting comes with a healthy dose of
self-deprecating humor it's one of those
things we're like I love you but I just
don't know if I like you despite the
chaos Justin says they want to make
Silas a big brother I mean I want to
have as many as we can if I'm being
honest right now Justin is focusing on
music February 2nd his new album man of
the woods drops two days later he takes
on the Super Bowl halftime stage a lot
of my music I would not play for my son
now although I did play filthy for a man
he's already got that haters gonna say
his fake lined up but he was like so
will I was like man when that are kicks
in Willy flesh son after first hinting
to EC that Jessica's voice has a cameo
at the end of the audio track for filthy
to see it may or may not be my wife
Justin told beats 1 radio Hossein low
that she is credited on the album and
his Queen will get royalties she gonna
put she gets all the points bro are you
married to how this works
he's got all my publisher
you
[Music]